okay wait a minute history has just been
made
breaking the all-time record for the
most grammy wins ever by any female
artist
or any singer male or female the grammy
goes to
[Applause]
beyonce
beyonce one name one artist and now
officially making history with 28
grammys
oh my god i am so honored i'm so excited
during sunday's 63rd annual grammy
awards the powerhouse talent
accepted her record-breaking 28th trophy
for best r b
performance for black parade off her
blackest king visual album
i wanted to uplift encourage
celebrate all of the beautiful black
queens and kings that
continue to inspire me and inspire the
whole world
but this award wasn't beyonce's only
victory earlier in the night she also
took home the grammy for best rap song
for savage remix with megan the stallion
beyonce has just tied the all-time
record for most grammy wins
ever by a female artist and by any
singer
male or female so congratulations queen
bee
she set a record tonight how important
was that too
it's very important uh as just a black
woman entertainer
uh black women in general um we here
we're here to stay we're here to take
over we've been doing that
but like just shout out to beyonce for
making her story tonight
and get this beyonce wasn't the only
carter family member to go home a winner
and the grammy goes to beyonce
blue ivy and wizkid yeah beyonce's
nine-year-old daughter blue ivy took
home
her first grammy for best music video
for her and her mom's song
brown skin girl
[Music]
later in the night beyonce acknowledged
her baby girl's milestone moment during
her speech
in blue congratulations she won a grammy
tonight
i'm so proud of you and i'm so honored
to be
your mommy all of your mommies y'all are
my babies
and i'm so proud of y'all and of course
her grandma tina knowles lawson
couldn't be prouder oh my gosh she's
amazing
shortly after blue nabbed her first
grammy tina took to instagram
sharing a snippet of the music video
alongside the caption quote
congratulations to my beautiful talented
granddaughter for being one of the
youngest grammy winners
for brown skin girl you go my blue blue
so proud of you i never tried to for
anybody else singing
you